the first award will be revealed by the
motion picture association executive who
has become Hollywood's movies ambassador
to the world and represented by the lady
who was first the first one to win an
Oscar two times in a row in 1936 for the
great Ziegfeld and in 1937 for the good
earth here are the distinguished mr.
Jack Valenti and the legendary Louise
Reiner
I am terribly happy to be here this
place this industry is part of my life
always has been but I think that when I
got my Academy Awards I didn't even have
radio coverage and now we have worldwide
TV television how wonderful how exciting
and what a chance it's only filling
penny magician right MGM turned its back
lot into of all things China and today's
filmmakers have turned the entire globe
into a backlog yes you're quite right
as matter of fact today most industry
most nations at their own film industry
and tonight the Academy is going to
honor the best form film and I'd be joy
in the honor to congratulate the
nominees who are as in Oh in the condom
a Nicaraguan home with dragon reduction
made of course in Nicaragua coup d'etat
sha clean slate film the lacquer
production France the flight of the
eagle it's a boy production where the
Swedish king
Swedish television SVT to Swank film
industry a norsk film is production
Sweden is in her private life of mosfilm
studio production from the USSR World
War I in Tehran
I think I better say to begin again that
is really the translation and not a
Nickelodeon film production made in
Spain that
that's angular I'll let you speak the
name he be witness
all my life since I was a kid I have
dreamed of this moment well the twins
come true sometimes and that's the thing
I want to spread my congratulate you and
me gratitude to my panel I my friend
Jose Steve and Linda and my friends and
Rica Raiders and meet on Colston and had
my late friend
Alfonso Sanchez and also 20 Century Fox
and the Academy and now allow me to say
in my own language estamos todos los que
hemos hecho esta película muy contento
we add ratios of steadies tambien todos
los que hacemos sin mi Pais en españa
thank you very very much
isn't it thrilling to see Miss Reiner
back here I miss another and you know
something mr. Valenti was right I mean
if they remade the good earth now I mean
they couldn't Metro they couldn't
recreate it again on the backlot they
have to do it in Yugoslavia or something